échanges et approfondir et questionner
rien de mieux pour s'est orientée que de
rencontrer centre de formation ni
employeur pour la rentrée ces jeunes
entre 15 et 30 ans sont venus nombreux
hier au forum yvelinois de
l'apprentissage si trouver un lycée à
saint germain en laye c'est pas très
loin de chez moi et du combat ça
m'intéresse parce que parcours super je
suis encore en attente de suez
je pense que du coup bas ce sera pas
prêt si près du coeur je pense que si je
serais pas venu ici j'aurais pu aider
quelqu'un une trentaine d'organismes de
formation en apprentissage
on proposait plus de 600 offres aux
apprentis comme aux employeurs notre
rôle nous c'est trouver les jeunes pour
les entreprises qui viennent nous voir
en disant on veut des apprentis dans tel
ou tel domaine
mais on accompagne aussi les jeunes
contrôler les structures depuis quelques
années des métiers plus atypiques ou au
contraire traditionnels font leur grand
retour
il ya un regain il ya de la demande dans
la boulangerie pâtisserie ya plus de
jeunes qu'avant et c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça qu'on a ouvert ses formations qu'on
n'avait pas avant dans notre école parce
que les émissions de télé ont fait
beaucoup pour de nombreux apprentis
c'est l'occasion d'échanger avec des
écoles mais aussi et surtout avec de
nombreux professionnels présentent sur
le forum en venu aussi espère trouver
une école est aussi un patron au fait
pourquoi comment sont en baisse
trouver un patron principale motivation
de cette journée et pour cause en
moyenne 70% des jeunes passés par
l'apprentissage entre l'emploi sept mois
après la fin de leur contrat